[Musique]
sur une plage balinaise nous avons
rendez vous avec de drôles d'oiseaux
aller 1 2 3 go
enfin plutôt un poisson géant qu'ils
veulent
recul maintenant bazille j'allais le
dire dire dire lâche tout là il faut
donner du lest
[Musique]
cela fait des mois qu'il s'entraîne pour
que leurs poissons flirte avec les
ménages ils ont travaillé dur
il faut qu'on s'entraîne c'est super
important parce que ce cerf-volant on ne
l'a encore jamais essayé du coup il faut
qu'on puisse corriger tous ses défauts
avant la compétition
lâcher maintenant lâché
dans quelques jours cette équipe va
défier les plus grands cerfs-volants du
monde
on va gagner
[Musique]
et parce que
ce sont des géants des airs de plusieurs
centaines de mètres
la légende raconte qu'il sont les
messagers des hommes on les fait voler
pour demander aux dieux de la récolte
et la tradition s'est transformée en
guerre des cieux chaque été tous balises
à fond pour gagner une compétition hors
normes
ne vous méprenez pas sur l'île des dieux
le cerf-volant c'est bien plus qu'un
simple jeu d'enfant
[Musique]
le son du gong appelle ces villageois
nous sommes à sano au sud de l'île
ici tous les billets appartiennent à un
benger une organisation de quartier et
tous majeurs qui se respecte à son
équipe de cerfs-volants
ça c'est là que du cerf-volant elle va
faire 130 m quand elle sera terminée
aggoun et le meneur de l'équipe à 26 ans
il a déjà conçu des dizaines de
cerfs-volants mais cette année il a vu
les choses en grand
avec sa bande ils construisent un jag
and un cerf volant dragons de 50 kg
bon dans la vie ils sont étudiants
livreur banquiers et n'en déplaise à
leurs petites amies tout leur temps
libre ils le passent ici
on se connaît depuis l'âge de 6 ans et
aujourd'hui moi j'en ai 24 alors vous
pouvez compter depuis combien d'années
on travaille ensemble sur des
cerfs-volants
[Musique]
bon
à bali cette tradition c'est bien plus
qu'une passion pour certains c'est même
devenu une religion
à l'autre bout de la ville nous avons
rendez vous avec le dieu vivant du
cerf-volant son atelier est le plus
réputé de lire
[Musique]
sur comme acteur il ya 7 cm là à la
ville cadets qui est un homme d'affaires
brillant le reste du temps c'est un
ingénieur fou avec ses artisans il manie
le bon bout comme personne chaque pièce
est sculpté main un travail d'orfèvre de
la haute couture volante
plus de dix ans à chaque festival de
cerfs-volants la plupart de mes
créations ont gagné la première deuxième
ou troisième place
et si québec est un homme respecté c'est
pour son invention un cerf-volant
démontable et du coup plus facilement
transportable depuis à bali les
cerfs-volants vont tripler de volume
et pour s'offrir son rêve de gosse il
n'a pas hésité à débourser une petite
fortune 5000 euros
il n'y a aucun mot qui puisse décrire
mon bonheur de voir l'un de mes
cerf-volant volée
et ça ça n'a pas de prix les gens vont
se rappeler de nous comme une équipe
imbattable
et vous savez sur l'île c'est la
reconnaissance août
[Musique]
jusqu'au bout de la nuit québec et son
équipe vont découper cours assemblée il
faut faire vite
une grande cérémonie doit avoir lieu
pour bénir le cerf-volant
mais elle doit se tenir avant minuit
pour ne pas attirer les dépôts
[Musique]
même la télévision balinaise et l'un
parce que québec possède un objet très
convoité
ce masque de dragon le visage du
cerf-volant
c'est le plus vieux de lille et d'après
la légende il pourrait même volé sans
vent
[Musique]
c'est un petit garçon gelé vu de mes
propres yeux ce jour là avec le peu de
vent qu'il y avait c'était impossible de
le faire voler et pourtant il s'est
envolé
les décoller doucement et il a volé
c'était juste incroyable
[Musique]
ce cerf-volant serait magique
alors il faut prier
par mysticisme par dévotion
le dragon doit donner sa bénédiction
avant de voler
parce qu'il est sacrée mais surtout
parce qu'il serait habité par un esprit
il est toujours là dans ce masque je
peux le sentir vous sentez quoi
c'est
quelque chose de difficile à expliquer
il est là ici
mais je préfère ne pas en parler
s'il vous plaît
mais c'est si sensible que ça
oui bien sûr c'est pour ça que l'on
vénère ce cerf-volant
[Musique]
au québec c'est le grand jour est le
début d'un marathon il faut traverser
toute la ville à pied le poids de la
tradition
c'est vraiment lourd
et pour les autres équipes de lille ça
ressemble à ça
une mafia aérienne
le belle carrosserie sont de sortie
l'important c'est d'être vu et reconnu
[Musique]
et parmi eux on retrouve aggoun notre
jeune l'humeur et sa bande eux aussi ont
déployé les gros moyens pour se faire
remarquer
on est vraiment les plus beaux vous
voyez tout le monde nous regarde et nous
laisse passer c'est génial la rue nous
appartient
mais sur le terrain ils vont moins faire
les malins
[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue au 35ème festival de
cerfs-volants de padang halak amusez
vous bien
mieux équipes ont affronté un millier de
concurrents venus de tout belle
au programme des monstres de 15 m
[Applaudissements]
et des adversaires prêts à tout pour
gagner
le combat des aires s'annonce musclé
[Musique]
parce que par le côté à part le côté la
première sueur froide pour aegon avec sa
bande il a bien du mal à atteindre la
piste de décollage dans cette
fourmilière de concurrents la tension
monte
loin du chaos il y en a fait preuve de
stratégie
on va partir d'ici
cadec s'est exilé sur une pauline
à deux kilomètres de ses concurrents
grâce à cette hauteur il va directement
prendre le vent
salle avantage de partir d'ici
c'est parti et lancez-vous fait voler
vos cerveaux lents
[Musique]
pour les équipes il faut faire vite ils
n'ont qu'un seul essai pour hisser leur
géant à plus de 200 mètres du sol
[Musique]
il faut dompter l'animal pour qu'ils se
laissent admirer
temps minimum de vol 20 minutes où c'est
l'élimination
un ballet aérien une performance des
équipes jugées par des experts dans les
moindres détails
pas mal l'atterrissage est bon
giuly est l'un d'entre eux
absolument tout est noté depuis le
décollage jusqu'à l'atterrissage du
cerveau nord
sa fabrication ces proportions la
composition de ses couleurs
mais le critère le plus important c'est
son harmonie dans les airs
[Musique]
parce que
le cerf-volant c'est le miroir de notre
vie qui doit être en harmonie avec ce
que nous sommes
c'est notre principe de vie à nous les
balinais
en somme une compétition très spirituel
qui ne l'empêchent pas d'être injuste
l'ordre de passage est imposé quelle que
soit la force du vent
hénart il n'y en a plus
[Musique]
c'est le début d'une série noire deux
crashs navy table
dites nous si on va décoller nous on est
prêts
non ce n'est pas bon il n'y a pas de
vent du tout
à contrecoeur l'équipe d'agde ou
n'abandonne la manche trop risqué nous
les retrouvons pour leur deuxième
tentative taux moins d'une heure
à l'autre bout du terrain qu'avec lui il
ne coûte rien
ce qui le préoccupe c'est la non pas
pour une c'est d'apporter la cagole sous
40°
avec un bon travail d'équipé on peut pas
rater une déco l'arrière c'est confiance
bien sûr évidemment de toute façon pas
question de faire marche arrière cadec
joue sa réputation
tout le monde attend de voir si son
dragon magique peut effectivement volé
sans vent
et lancez-vous
[Musique]
la magie n'a pas opéré
l'impensable s'est produit
c'est raté à cause du vent
il n'a visiblement plus le coeur à nous
répondre
il ya quelque chose de cassé allez
vérifier vite
dans sa chute l'oiseau sacré a perdu de
sa splendeur il lui manque trois dans
peut-être un mauvais présage
on est vraiment déçu je pense que l'on
n'a pas assez briller on a dû faire une
erreur pendant le rituel est maintenant
on doit faire une nouvelle cérémonie on
rentre à la maison
[Musique]
pour cadec c'est terminé c'est la
première fois en vingt ans qu'il est
éliminé
mais d'autres n'ont pas dit leur dernier
mot
attends attends il faut qu'ils nous
appellent d'abord
à gond temps de sa dernière chance il
reste encore une manche celle du bébé
and le cerf-volant poissons
et ça tombe bien ils en ont
[Musique]
alethia le piano
ils sont plus de 25 dans les airs le but
du jeu c'est le même pour tous faire
danser leurs poissons sont qu'il percute
les autres
[Musique]
attention là
notre position est bien là mais il ya
vraiment trop de concurrents
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est la fin de la manche et là il faut
rattraper l'animal sans le faire tomber
[Musique]
on est super content il a bien volé
pour le savoir ils vont devoir attendre
encore quelques jours le temps que le
jury délibère
[Musique]
on espère vraiment que notre cerveau
lent arrive premier si on gagne ce sera
un cadeau des dieux
une semaine plus tard de retour sur la
plage de san ou re
il immortalise leur fine équipe ils
n'ont finalement rien gagné mais
qu'importe
ils se sont offert des souvenirs en
partage
cadec lui a déjà oublié sa défaite
maintenant ils s'entraînent pour son
seul plaisir
son dragon sacré a finalement rejoint
les dieux je suis sans voix de le voir
voler enfin c'est magnifique incroyable
ça me renvoie en enfance en fait le voir
voler comme ça c'est beaucoup d'émotions
[Musique]
et même si le riz venait à manquer cette
année l'île sacrée aura su récolter
l'essentiel
l'harmonie de ses hommes qu'ils
continueront de faire rêver leurs dieux
[Musique]
une